that beautiful night can oh no not yet
okay okay shaq is threatening checkmate
ten seconds on the board the black rook
and black queen want to get into the
corner of the board so you have to block
the queen's diagonal still winning for
spit it's scary the white king is now
exposed he's winning but it's a little
bit scary at least now he has a night
check coming in white's knight was
threatening to come and check the black
king so marijuana had to lose a move
recruiting his king he's going for the
final kill he's got it has he got it
he's got it well done and it's a
celebration from eric hanson the chess
streamer and a handshake he beats world
number ten that's a huge performance by
the canadian
and look at him he's exhausting he must
be bursting with joy inside david how
impressed and happy are you for eric i'm
super happy for him i mean of course
commiserations to major if he put up a
great fight as well in that match kept
us entertained but eric i mean he was at
the bottom of the table before today
struggling